what do you think about communism well
that's the point of this book okay tell
us about it well it's really bad uh the
point of writing the white pill and this
has nothing to do with anarchism at all
um the book uh the point of the white
pill is I was kind of disquieted you
know being born in the former Soviet
Union to what extent it has been almost
being forgotten and this is something
that ended in our lifetime the lifetime
of everyone here and probably the vast
majority of people listening as well and
what people went through for decades on
the far side of the Iron Curtain was so
disturbing and also so hard for us to
wrap our heads around we let's I don't
know if any of you have diabetes I don't
right if someone tried to tell you what
it's like living with diabetes you're
it's going to be very different from
actually living it right we can wrap our
heads around okay I can't have candy are
there other health externalities you
know can I exercise maybe I'm gonna if I
want to take a marathon I'm gonna have
to do certain things we're still not
going to get there intellectually unless
you live it so we we can maybe
understand okay I'm in school I'm taught
certain things or someone's listening to
me on the phone or people get arrested
and you're powerless doing thing about
it we can maybe understand each of those
elements individually but in terms of
understanding that pervasive atmosphere
the tagline of the book it's let me get
the exact quote when Rand was testifying
in front of Congress she said it's
almost impossible to convey to a free
people what it's like to live in a
totalitarian dictatorship
so I try to explain throughout the
course of this book just what it was
like and even I don't really understand
it my protege was just in Prague they
have something there called The Museum
of Communism and that you know what's
great about this museum is it's not
written this western style in a
scholarly manner because it's like
according to these demented ideas we're
all supposed to have food but instead we
were starving and when I was when he
sent me all the photos of the captions
because I wanted to quote one for the
book it made me appreciate for the first
time what it was like for my family in
the sense of totalitarianism you know
this is stupid pun but it's not a pun
but it means total so it's everywhere
there's nowhere to go from the moment
you're born till the time you die and
you're told you can't leave so let's
suppose there's a politician you hate or
you hate politics in general you hate
Trump you think Biden's a fool you can
watch sports you can listen to music you
can read books historical books or
contemporary books
yes they're trying to put politics into
everything but there's certainly very
many venues where you could Escape or
even just talking to your friends they
didn't have that and even just talking
to your friends you have to wonder all
right did Pat turn is so or someone is
someone did someone get to him or is he
just doing this for status for money so
that kind of sense of having something
the government and that ideology govern
every aspect of your life is something
that I think is important for those of
us who love any semblance of Freedom
Republican or Democrat to appreciate so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]